Breton drums son-in-law is rejecting new
claims of business conflict of interest
Jared Kushner sister highlighted her
family and Krishna's white house ties
over the weekend she was in China asking
versed investors to put money into a New
Jersey housing development she pitched
the project as a way to qualified fourth
qualify for a US visa
Jericka Duncan is outside that Kushner
development one journal software in
Jersey City
Eureka good morning good morning this
property behind me has been vacant for
more than a decade the Kushner companies
purchased it back in December of 2014
now over the weekend Jared Kushner
sister was soliciting 150 million
dollars for this project she did it
using a controversial visa program that
was set to expire but was signed back
into law just one day before her pitch
reporters were shunned from publicized
events in China over the weekend
Jenna Jenna bucks Nicole Kushner Meyer
the sister of White House senior advisor
Jared Kushner was courting Chinese
investors urging them to invest in a New
Jersey luxury apartment complex Javier
Hernandez the New York Times China
correspondent was escorted from
Saturday's session at the ritz-carlton
hotel in Beijing
Nicole Meyer when she stood in that room
made sure that people knew that she was
part of this Kushner family that her
brother was in the administration for
$500,000 investors could get a path to
American citizenship through the eb-5
government program which grants green
cards to entrepreneurs who invest in US
enterprises during this course of this
event they displayed the president's
image because they were identifying him
as a key decision-maker on these
so-called eb-5 visas Nicole Meyer
herself said this project means a lot to
me and my family this is an abuse of
power and they should not be allowed
Richard painter is a former chief White
House Ethics lawyer we can't have a
situation where public officials and
their families are using those programs
to enrich themselves a Kushner company
spokesman said the firm apologizes if
that mention of her brother was in any
way interpreted as an
attempt to lure investors that was not
Miss Myers intention but Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner has emerged as
a major diplomatic channel between China
and the Trump administration his
personal lawyer said that Kushner has no
involvement in the operation of Kushner
companies and divested his interest in
the one journal square and that he will
recuse from particular matters
concerning the eb-5 visa program Kushner
has benefited from the eb-5 program
before and the base street Trump
property it's an apartment complex has
also received 50 million dollars from
eb-5 investors many of whom are Chinese
nationals Nora
all right Rica thank you so much